caught on camera a british fighter jet
tracking a russian bomber close to uk
airspace the first of two raf scrambles
in as many days
a starring role for the russian pilot
too
this footage rather unusually released
by russia's defense ministry
state propaganda from the cold war
playbook yet it was filmed this week as
the kremlin is locked in an increasingly
heated contest with western allies over
ukraine
signaling strength from the ground as
well
russian troops training in belarus close
to ukraine's border
information and images like these used
as a weapon of influence under the
threshold of war it's a tactic deployed
by both sides in fact ukraine's deputy
defense minister said warnings by allies
like the u.s and the uk about the threat
of a new russian invasion of her country
[Music]
in the latest expose the us claimed
russia is planning to frame ukrainian
forces in a staged attack against a
russian target
the uk also has high confidence moscow
is hatching such a plot as part of this
fake attack
we believe that russia would produce a
very graphic propaganda video
which would include corpses
and actors that would be depicting
mourners
and images of destroyed locations
yet more evidence that information and
physical weapons are permanently
combined in this complex battle space
debra haynes sky news kiev